cuál es la medida del ángulo c v aquí
tenemos a c aquí tenemos a ho y aquí
tenemos a b y por lo tanto nos están
pidiendo determinar la medida de este
ángulo pero no nos la dan no podemos
simplemente copiar el número lo que sí
nos dan es la medida de este ángulo de
aquí que es un ángulo adyacente es un
ángulo adyacente porque si los pensamos
como rayos uv b ó c o d entonces estos
dos ángulos tienen al rayo en común a
este rayo de acá estos también los
podemos pensar como rayos vale y además
nos dicen cuál es la medida del ángulo
de o b y como el ángulo de uve está
formado por los ángulos adyacentes 45 e
interrogación entonces la medida de 45
más la de interrogación debe ser la
medida del dv es decir 70 grados eso lo
podemos escribir como sigue la medida de
interrogación lo voy a poner aquí
interrogación
a 45 grados más 45 grados es igual a la
medida del ángulo que forman entre los
dos es igual a 70 a 70 grados y de aquí
podemos restar 45 de ambos lados para
obtener que la medida de interrogación
es igual a 70 grados a 70 grados menos
45 grados y eso cuánto nos quedaría pues
saber 70 menos 40 es 30 pero hay que
restar otros 5 entonces nos quedaría 25
de este modo la medida de interrogación
es 25 grados que lo voy a apuntar aquí
interrogación mide 25 grados muy bien